hey what's going on it's Bill Burr and
it's time for the Thursday afternoon
just before Friday Monday Morning
podcast and I'm just checking it
just checking in to see how your week's
going man
how everything's going oh you're having
a rough one are ya
you know well guess what nobody wants to
hear about it
you know that's what therapists are for
God bless therapist he's gonna sit there
listening to people bitching
whining about their lives
and then they got to be like well why
why don't you try a different thing next
time I don't know it's just
I don't know why I guess I just feel
that you know
the option isn't open for me
well it is open for you
you know just try to go around the wall
rather than keep ramming your head into
it
I don't know I just I just feel like
there's a lot of stuff coming up right
now
and it's just like I know like I know
what you're saying is right but like I'm
just like not there yet do you know what
I mean can you imagine listening to that
and then looking at the clock and then
going like oh my God it's almost over
it's almost [__] over and then
knowing that another person is going to
come in there
start all over again
oh yeah I mean uh
I I just don't feel feelings
okay so when you say you don't feel
feelings like
what does that mean
I mean like I mean if I'm watching a
game and like you know
I got money on it
and my wife's staring the pot too loud
and I'm losing the bet like you know I
feel feelings down but like
I mean if there's like a bird chirping
it's it just kind of annoys me which
all right well being annoying is it's
actually an emotion
you are feeling things you just
no I mean like I want to like
take the bird and twist its head off
okay I think we've done enough for one
day
um
anyway
Oh Billy freckles getting ready to go
back on the road I had a great show last
night I ran my hour I did my whole hour
oh boy who's a big boy who did his whole
hour
oh did you put on your little clown
shoes Billy Oh Billy clown shoes got on
stage the other night did his whole hour
like a big boy didn't take any breaks
wow
look at you
the old bearded blunder went on went on
stage last night ran my hour
did about an hour and fifty an hour and
20.
um I got a whole bunch of new [__] up
front that finally like uh I feel tied
the hour together I know what my next
special is going to be called I know how
I'm gonna work it and I'm doing that for
the rest of the year I am [__]
motivated I'm excited
I'm working out I'm stretching
I dropped some weight
I'm ready to go
I'm ready to go do some damage up there
in Ottawa
I'm going to that [__] Ottawa
Senators Toronto Maple Leafs game yeah
that's right
that's right you're jealous the last
Canadian team I need to see
unless I start going to [__] CFL
games
Jesus Christ and those [__] up
stadiums
you know what I mean you ever see the
you ever see a CFL Stadium
you know if they have a reshot like
Mississippi Burning
you know that era of America
or you know
where you have like the less Dramatics
type of guys like they should you know
and there's any sort of
something revolved around sports or like
maybe when they do like the sports like
the uh like some college
you know they're gonna have their first
black player
and you know
the white Coach is like just not smart
enough to play football everybody knows
you want a white running back in a white
wide receipt
they're doing that and they need like an
old school looking football stadium they
should shoot it up
and like Winnipeg one of those ones even
the one in Toronto I thought I saw it
it's like the thing where you got like
stands on both Sidelines in it but it's
open ended on either side
like those ones like how you can
literally be sitting in the in in the
grandstands and you can look out and see
your car in the parking lot
NFL games used to look like that
I remember watching the Minnesota
Vikings and they would line up for a
field goal and they you know they would
have the shot behind the field goal
kicker and you're looking at cars in the
parking lot
there'd be like [__] two guys back
there
running around to catch the football
before it [__] rolled down a hill or
something that I'm telling you right
there
that was a [__] football stadium
all right and that was still in America
in America
was it way up there in in uh uh uh what
do you call it up there in Canada
where it's even more cold it's it's like
it's almost like Canadians are trying to
be colder
well wait they start their football
season earlier
I don't know I just drove by what it was
a Toronto Argonauts and I am going to go
to I'm gonna start going to CFL games
I mean you always have to have something
that you're looking forward to when
you're on the road or a goal
or else you just get that [__] 600
yard stare on your face and you're just
like what have I done with my life
I thought this was going to be exciting
I thought I was going to enjoy it
I mean I did for the first 25 years but
I'll tell you hey I'll tell you these
last
these last seven have been a little
rough okay
yeah
that's the hard thing is going to a city
that you've been to
a thousand [__] times and finding
something new to do something that
excites you something that you can look
forward to so you keep your [__] Mojo
you know
you're you're up
you know you're not coming like oh my
God
like I've been to Ottawa a bunch of
times I've skated along the canal I do
that again
I would do that in a second I'd skate
along that [__] Canal get myself a
little hot chocolate if you've never
done it I'm telling you it's such an
underrated thing
um not for a Canadian
you know I mean those [__] people
they skate backwards to work
you know apologizing the whole way
I love that they have that reputation
you know oh hey oh sorry they're not
like that maybe in like the cities where
there's like money involved
you know
there's money involved they got skin in
the game
I'm not talking about the Cosmopolitan
you know person that lives in Canada
who was a friend that looks like Drake
I'm not talking about that person I'm
talking about those [__] animals
that live in the middle of nowhere
on like a farm
and they got their own [__] pond
and their dad built a rink
you know and at the end of the game
every night you have to fight all your
brothers
and whoever wins
you know gets the first cut of [__]
elk
or bison or polar bear whatever those
[__] people
I'm literally just making [__] up I've
never been
well I've driven through it
you know I've driven through the farm
areas in Canada I drove from Winnipeg up
to Regina
and I looked at The Farms
and I felt the exact same thing I feel
when I drive by American Farms
which is there's a good chance a serial
killer lives in there
[Laughter]
there was just something so creepy
if you just drive by a farm
you know it's beautiful right you want
to take the easel out of your trunk put
a canvas up you know
and paint that little red bar and that's
in a state of disrepair peeking Over the
Horizon you know
that one random cow just standing there
looking at you you're looking at it
but you really take a look at the
[__] place
you know if you stay there till the Sun
starts going down you know
that's when all the secrets start coming
out man it just it's really a farm is a
really
creepy thing you know what it's all the
same [__]
is a big part of me that wants to live
in the middle of [__] nowhere I was
thinking that yesterday when I was
driving in the traffic out here
and how my entire adult life
since I moved out like I grew up in the
suburbs which I feel is the perfect
amount of you're close to the city
you know you're not in the city you're
not in the country a lot of people make
fun of the suburbs suburbs are the [__]
you know
you're close enough to the city where
you can go in there and get some culture
meet different people
and see Independent films and all of
that stuff but you're not gonna like you
know
start stealing cars
all right while you get ridiculously
good at math
um
but if you live in the middle of nowhere
that's when you get like oh paranoid
you know
which is totally understandable I mean
you're just out there by yourself
and it's really all on you I mean if
somebody comes through your front door
you can't yell help
that's why people in the middle of
nowhere have all of those [__] guns
and all of these [__] liberals that
live in cities if they lived out there
in the middle of nowhere they'd have a
[__] gun too and if you don't you're
an idiot
you're a [__] idiot I mean some of
these people their [__] driveways are
like a quarter of a mile long
when I would be out there doing College
gigs make a left on Rural Road l like
they didn't even have a [__] name
they were barely paved you [__] live
out there
all right
and your next door neighbor who's
[__] nine miles away
starts getting into the meth he starts
dipping into you know he gets high on
his own Supply
and he turns into a [__] zombie and
all of a sudden he starts walking up
your [__] driveway
all he's got on is apparel overalls
nothing else looking like [__] Tom
Sawyer
walking up the goddamn driveway with
[__] bad intentions what are you
gonna do
huh
you're gonna go over to that phone on
the wall
operator yeah let me get the sheriff
yeah
let me get Pennsylvania's six nine
Fiverr or whatever the [__] they I mean
they don't even have [__] cell phones
out there
kidding
that right there is a a it's a silo and
a cell phone tower I got my own [__]
Network out here I grow my own [__]
food
I'm building a rocket
um
yeah somebody comes up you [__]
driveway out there you're gonna call the
cops
huh you can wait for Sheriff Fresco Pico
train to come up in some [__]
Plymouth
four hours later and this guy you know
this guy's a farmer
all right
this guy knows how to fillet meat and
he's on [__] crack and whatever the
[__] he's on that wooden teeth [__]
crystal meth
by the time they get there you're gonna
be like that Garden [__] Silence of
the Lambs remember when he put them up
all gutted and he looked like it was on
the front of a boat
you know what the worst part is is the
sheriff's gonna know the name of the guy
that kills you
can sit there like all right all right
now Forrest you had your fun
okay put the lawnmower blade down
now God damn it
bill is all kinds of [__] up up there
and I he's still breathing now this
let's just be fair you had your fun let
me cut him down
don't reach into that little pocket
don't reach into that little pocket in
front of your overalls
pulls out a sick shooter and then he
misses
he's got a basset hound sitting on his
[__] dashboard
um yeah you gotta have a gun when you're
out there but the problem is when you
live out there
all you can do is talk to your neighbor
who's like nine miles away and you live
in the middle of nowhere
right
and the people in the cities are making
fun of you so you're like [__] them
straight across the board so you won't
listen to their information
so now all you're left with is you and
your friend
who lives nine miles away and your
interpretation of the internet
[Laughter]
and that's when you start connecting
dots man
I'll tell you what you know what they're
doing you know what I think they're
doing what do you think they're doing
I'll tell you right now I'll tell you
right now what the [__] is going on all
right
I went to I figureditout.net I read some
[__] it's fresh in my brain and I want
to say it to you before forget it
you like how I'm making it seem like
only people in the South live in the
middle of nowhere I always call myself
out on doing that but I continue to do
it
that's that small town thing does exist
everywhere
you know I remember when I moved to New
York and one of my buddies lives in the
suburbs of Boston
and he's like where do you live in New
York where you live and I said I live on
97th and Lex
he's like dude what's up with the
numbers down there like all the streets
are like numbers
like well it kind of makes it easy
there's like [__] 200 streets do you
want to name 200 streets on a little ass
Island and it is a little last Island
you know you could walk from one side to
the other in like a [__] hour
you know I guess you can do that
probably in any City I don't know
I was just always amazed
at how small the City Manhattan was once
once you got in it and you started to
know people
the amount of times you'd walk down the
street and just run into somebody you
knew
hey
it's like this is not possible
there's like a billion people all
stacked up on top of each other does hey
anybody over there in China listening
does that ever happen in like Hong Kong
I went to Hong Kong man
[__] I'm still thinking about the food
that I ate there
and the energy of that place God damn it
that was fun
underrated underrated going to Asia
um
oh yeah all these [__] idiots want to
go to the Moon
and go to Mars if you want the
experience
of feeling like you went to another
planet but there's still oxygen
I'm sorry and you could take a plane
home
right
you can take a plane home and not worry
about burning up during re-entry
go to Asia unless you're from Asia and
if you're living Asia come over here I
swear to God
when I went over there what what blew my
[__] mind
was it was a completely alternate
universe with all the exact same [__]
all all called something different
bunch of commercial airlines I know I
know I've talked about this before but
there's always new listeners
like to this day I want to know what the
airline was when we landed in Hong Kong
coming in from Singapore which was also
amazing
um
God I gotta go back this is just making
me want to go back when we landed we
were taxing into the gate and I saw this
white airplane
and on the tail it had a red like this
dragon
on the back and I was looking at me and
going dude what the [__] Airline is that
we were in Singapore here it was all
these new Airlines they had all their
own famous people all their own shows
you put on the TV and you literally
watching shows that it's like their
version of the American show and then
you start thinking like wait did we rip
them off or are they ripping us off
because you know that's Show Business
around the world everybody's just like
hey that show Works let's do the [__]
Swahili version of Road Rules
um
so anyway like the food was all amazing
but then what just blew my mind was just
the sheer amount of people over there
and you'd be like when you drive from
the airport to go to downtown Hong Kong
I felt like
every like 10 miles there was like a
Manhattan
of just an impossible amount of
skyscraper apartment buildings all
clustered together
um
and you're like all of those are filled
up with people and then you go another
few and then there'd be like another was
I mean
I mean it's an environmental disaster
who's kidding who but it's like the fact
that it still somehow works
is incredible
as we have a tornado
we had a tornado here in La yesterday
okay the weird wacky weather of global
warming it's gonna be [__] crazy
riding this out I've just decided I'm
just gonna [__]
enjoy global warming and just watch
I'm just gonna act like I'm watching
like a real live Tom Cruise Will Smith
movie because they're [__] they're
not doing anything about it once again
it rained out here
and all the [__] water drains into
the LA River and they just let it go out
into the [__] ocean and we've gotten
so much [__] rain out here this year
so so much [__] rain and like it's
like 80 percent of it just goes out into
the ocean I guarantee you by mid April
they're going to be like we're we're
still in a drought
um if you're gonna steal water
from the rest of the state from Colorado
if we're going to participate in the
reason why as a city the reason why the
Colorado River no longer reaches the
ocean for the last [__] 20 years you
think the least we could do is save our
[__] rain water we don't do it but
anyway
the question I wanted to ask of people
that live in Hong Kong is do you do you
ever just like run into people you know
over there
or the worse somebody you broke up with
that's what always blew up blew my mind
in Manhattan you'd be like you know
get out of a relationship
and you know right when you were
starting to feel better you know the
loneliness you know okay I can turn it
around I'll find somebody else
yeah who comes walking up the street
you're Rex and you're like ah [__]
here we go right in the night see you
like hey how you doing yeah good time
you talk and then it would just start
the mind [__] all over again you're just
thinking like how the what are the
[__] odds
what are the [__] odds
I'm nowhere near her apartment or my
apartment here we are done what the [__]
are we doing you know
anyway I'm sorry
um
I gotta go to a [__] funeral today I
gotta go to the service for my um my
masseuse spreading the ashes there
um
so now I am trying
I'm trying to find somebody else because
my shoulder's already [__] up in my
Jedi
Diana Linden is no longer here man I
don't think I've ever uh
lost someone like this I've lost amazing
amazing friends but she was an amazing
friend who also
um through her work just the quality of
life that I lived
all of the stuff that she I mean
literally just me moving every time I
moved was easier because of her and uh
God damn it
those people are healers if you can find
I'll tell you that right now underrated
in your adult life I also the Younger
You Are
if you can find a Jedi masseuse
and you can figure out a way to go to
that person I don't on a regular basis
like the level of quality of life that
you're gonna live
I'm telling you that that's probably the
most underrated thing I would say when
you're a young person is because you're
young
you know you don't feel like you need to
take care of your body
it's like you got a new car and you're
doing burnouts and [__] neutral drops
and all of that [__] and like you can do
those
but eventually you know the [__]
starts falling out
at the bottom of the car and like I
really if I could have gone if I could
go back
and redo my life
I literally would have started getting
massages
in like high school
when I first [__] up my back and
everything like that and it's just like
there's just so much
less stuff to undo as opposed to
um
I didn't start getting worked on until I
was like 47. wow
[Applause]
that also seems young to me
um
so um
I figured out what's going on with me
with this cough and everything it's just
that you know
I feel like I just my daughter keeps
coming home from school she catches
colds and then she gives it to my son
and they just keep giving him back and
forth like throw out
winner if you just have kids
in these damn schools because
my lungs are fine I'm not smoking by the
way everybody
I feel so good about that I thought
about it it's also pretty easy because
it's cold out and it's raining
my back porch is [__] drenched
maybe I can wring out the cushions and
save that water
um
I feel really good about it like
I sleep better better and all of that
[__]
and uh
I don't know it's definitely obvious I'm
stating the obvious but anyway if you're
a young person I would
try to go out I mean I know it's
expensive and that's type of [__] but
like to get a massage and stuff but like
the investment is 100 worth it
um
you know and just go out
a couple of
nights less during the course of a month
and invest in in a uh
a massage
and then if you can work out too you
know and do a complete workout figure
out how to do that and eat right and
everything I'm telling you like you will
live a quality of life I would think
until 70.
um at least and you know at some point
nature does take over but um anyway
let's do the live read here everybody oh
look who it is it's all zip brick crude
you know if you were to start a new
business what would it be
a taco truck business
a bouncy castle human trafficking
a slaughterhouse
uh camcorder repair
for the hipsters in your neighborhood
whether you're starting a new business
or growing one if you want it to be
successful you need the most talented
people on your team this is where
comes in
and right now you can try it for free at
ziprecruiter.com
why why should you let zip
there
help you hire
for your business well because those
z-town's powerful matching technology
finds highly qualified candidates
for a wide range of roles this is how
bad my eyes are it said
let's zip recruiter I thought it said
Led Zeppelin it's just like oh [__]
Robert Plant's got some money in this
company
um
let's zip ah uh fill all your roles with
the right candidates four to five
employees employers who post on zipper
crew get a quality candidate within the
first day see for yourself go to this
exclusive web address to try
ZipRecruiter for free ziprecruiter.com
again that zip
.com spell outbur b-u-r-r sip recruiter
the smartest way to hire
oh look who it is everybody liquid death
liquid death and I got to be honest
people I have skin in this game I bought
some shares in this company I got to let
you know that
but I do believe in this because I
believe in this company
you know they got bottled water in
aluminum cans first of all it tastes way
better
all right simple uh idea here would you
you want to drink a cold beer out of a
plastic bottle
all right of a nice old beer can
of course the beer can it's going to
taste way better same thing with the
water and the great thing about the beer
can is it's [__] it's recyclable like
a a a a plastic bottle but the bottom
line is nobody's [__] recycling you
put in the blue bin they just throw it
in the ocean this aluminum can will
actually break down as opposed to that
bottled water
that empty plastic bottled water uh
container which is going to stay in the
ocean for 800 to A Thousand Years and
every time you're eating sushi part of
that [__] plastic bottle is going to
be in your sushi
or you could drink liquid death do I
even need to read the copy at this point
by now you've probably seen liquid death
or maybe you've heard me talk about
their Mountain Water and flavored
Sparkling Waters that look just like
tall boys now they have a new line of
iced tea that I love these things are
[__] Delicious By the way these cans
of iced tea are healthy unlike a lot of
those other Iced Teas that are loaded
with sugar these are highly sweetened
with six grams of Premium Agave like a
top shelf tequila they're only 30
calories and provide a micro dose of 30
grams of caffeine per tall boy uh
they're also enhanced with B vitamins
there are three flavors of iced tea Grim
leafer rest in peace Peach armless
Palmer armless Palmer
um liquid deaths new Iced Teas are
available now with free shipping on
Amazon and retailers near you as an
added bonus Monday Morning podcast
listeners get 20 off their first liquid
death apparel purchase available
exclusively at liquiddeath.com
exclusions May apply that's
liquiddeath.com all right lastly but not
leastly then I'm gonna have to end this
podcast because I can't be late
for the funeral here uh policy genius
you know a good life insurance plan can
give you peace of mind that if something
happens to you your family will have a
safety net to cover mortgage payments
College costs are other expenses so they
can get back on their feet and focus on
what's more most important getting on
with their life after you've died with
policy genius you can find life
insurance policies that start at just 25
per month 25 per month for one million
dollars of coverage some for 25 a month
you can give your spouse motives to
collect a million dollars some options
are uh do you get a million dollars in
coverage for only 25 bucks I'd say start
making your own breakfast
um some options offer coverage in as
little as a week avoid unnecessary
medical exam policy genius has licensed
agents who can help you find the best
fit for your needs they work for you not
the insurance company that means they
don't have an incentive to recommend one
insurer over another or give uh or so
you can trust their guidance that's
right they got no skin in the game here
uh there's no added fees and your
personal details are private no wonder
they have thousands of five star
thousands of five star reviews on Google
and trust pilot your loved ones deserve
a financial safety net you deserve a
smarter way to find and buy it head to
policygenius.com or click the link in
the description to get your first free
life insurance quotes and see how much
you could save that's
policygenius.com if you're a [__] like
me
p-o-l-i-c-y genius is g-e-n-i-u-s
dot com all right that's it that's the
podcast enjoy the music from the
wonderfully talented Andrew thermalis
and um
and uh enjoy a bonus episode of the
Thursday afternoon just before Friday
Monday Morning podcast after this have a
wonderful weekend you cons
[Music]
hey what's going on
how are you hey it's Bill Burr and it's
the Monday Morning podcast for Monday
Monday March
23rd 2015. how's it going how are you
doing hopefully hopefully you're hearing
this thing on time if not sooner last
week I um
I recorded the thing on Sunday then of
course I brought the wrong [__] why
yeah so I couldn't upload it
right
and then [__] I do my Thursday one my
internet just sucks and my I don't know
what's going on like in my neighborhood
right they don't want you know when they
put those trees up it looks like a weird
looking tree but you can't really tell
unless you look at it and it gives you
good internet well in my neighborhood
they don't want that we don't want it it
affects the Integrity of the Landscaping
your neighborhood right so we don't have
one of those so my internet sucks a big
bag of dicks so what I have to do now it
just keeps getting worse by the week
and um I don't know if this is part of
some other [__] some big
conglomerates buying up bandwidth and
all this [__] where they try to squeeze
me down the [__] little porthole they
want me to go down I don't even know if
that's under the same category that's
just some [__] that I heard walking by a
TV in an airport
all right so don't hold me to that
um
all I know is now whenever I do my
[__] podcast what I have to do is I
then have to jump in the car after I
upload it and then drive down to a local
Starbucks
and I gotta stand there you know eating
a muffin waiting for the [__] thing
to upload actually I'm not I don't need
it I'm not eating a muffin all right
Oh Billy gym rat
huh
Oh Billy squat face
you know I want it
I've been going to the gym now for
[__] two weeks and
um you know I [__] up yesterday
a buddy of mine's parents were in town
who went to this Greek restaurant ate
like a [__] horse and uh you know
yeah it's just it's just [__] in my
age you just can't do that you can't
like negates two days of working out but
uh I'm still going to the gym
I'm holding steady I was I was 177.8
starting off at 184. I dropped seven
pounds almost a [__] lot more like
six pounds and uh I'm not stopping and
I'm gonna keep saying this because if I
don't tell you guys this you won't hold
it to me you won't hold it to me you
won't hold me to it
I gotta get down to Buck 62 the last
time or whatever [__] way did his
wife finally have a flat stomach or you
know what I mean what I've always said
all right there's
standing up flat stomach there's lying
down flat stomach and then the ultimate
shape is sitting down flat stomach
right
the ultimate truth is when you sit down
and you look down that's that's the
[__] shape you're in and I gotta tell
you I don't like it
I don't like it at all so you wouldn't
know by my coughing I haven't had a
cigar in a [__] month and I like it I
think I'm done with them for a while I'm
gonna I'm gonna smoke one New Year's my
birthday and then like that big college
game I go to every year and then that's
[__] it
you know what I mean I had this [__]
cough for like a few weeks you know some
sort of throat infection but I mentioned
to the guy that I smoked cigars and he
took his little [__] mirror and he
was looking at the side of my tongue for
cancerous lesions and immediately I'm
just like what am I doing
what am I an [__]
where do I get off smoking a cigar like
I just figured out the [__] economy
you know
like I just uh you know carved a path
towards World Peace
I have it all I did was come up with
more hateful hurtful misinterpreted
material that's all I've done I don't
deserve a cigar
um so anyways I've been going to the gym
I've just decided that going to the gym
is part of my day
all right it's not a part of my day that
I like I don't like the gym
you know you know the [__] song they
had on today remember that song y'all
ready for this
y'all ready for this I'm gonna start
saying my stupid uh
dubstep [__] why the [__] does it go
y'all ready for this
I can't remember how it goes it's like
it always places [__] awful keyboard
and then it stops and some dude asks you
are you all ready for this you know
they played that they played Herbie
Hancock though rocket which you know
I actually appreciate that song but I
mean I just don't understand why the
music has to be so bad so anyways I was
going to the gym
and I'm walking in my car I'm just
muttering like I don't want to do this I
don't want to do this I don't want to do
this
and it turned into I don't want to do
this I don't want to do this I don't
want to do this but the second I do this
it's over
all right
second I'm done it's over that's what I
just kept saying I don't want to do this
I don't want to do this I don't want to
do this but the second is done
it's over
and I'm [__] walking up the steps to
my gym uh you know when people [__]
walking out of the gym too I'm so
jealous of them that they're done
you know and people coming out of the
gym they're in a good mood they hold the
[__] door for you and [__] big smile
hey how are you get your workout on
right people [__] Dragon ass walking
into the gym they [__] open they
didn't look back at you they do
everything but slam the [__] dough on
your face right then you walk up to the
counter there's that little spunky perky
little chick there with their [__]
ponytails
pretend she doesn't realize that she
sort of dressed like a [__] you know
like something you'd order
you know what I mean what's with the
[__] [__] theme here you know
why can't you show up with your hair
like an adult okay
this is how much I ate the gym I'm
actually taking it out on this person
and she probably didn't look like that
at all right I just [__] hate it and
then you go over to the map where you're
gonna go stretch out and what happens
every time you go over there some [__]
is [__] and by [__] male or female
has sweated it on the [__] map and
didn't even wipe it up and even if they
did wipe it up you see that you're like
well what the [__] am I laying on here
right I shouldn't have wore shorts
it's [__] gross
so um
I don't know I haven't been in the gym a
while but the gym etiquette I don't know
what the [__] happened you know the deal
like if you're using a machine you use
it then you stand up right you sort of
walk around a little bit in case
somebody else wants to use it I was
doing legs today legs and eggs right
this [__] [__]
I do a set of the things you know where
you're sitting down you bring your
[__] feet up whenever you call those
things and then I go over to do the ones
where you're doing the back of your legs
and I do the squat machine
I'm going back again to the first one
it's called doing a little cycle there
right one two three the quote was called
bdp right you go [__] three of them
and I go back to the first one and it's
just [__] jerk off finishes the set
and then he's just sitting there
staring down at his [__] iPhone you
know
and I didn't say anything because the
last time that happened I said to this
lady I said hey can I work in she's like
what let me check out my earbuds what
I'm like can I work a setting and she's
like I only have two more and she just
puts it back in
ah I wanted to give her a [__] flare
chop
right right over the top of her [__]
breastices but you can't do that
can't do that now they're out of the
house they got jobs they can vote it's
[__] over
um there was a time when they weren't
even allowed at gyms
um
I don't know what it is I don't
understand that person I don't
understand the person that still uses
the [__] StairMaster this [__] guy
gets on right and you know those people
when they get on the StairMaster and
they stand on it what happens is the
[__] thing starts going down to the
ground that's when you're supposed to
step step up onto the other one they let
it go all the way down to the brown
ground with both legs and then he just
go
like little step little step little step
little if they're not doing anything and
then they're just [__] like clinging
to the top of the machine like they have
boat capsized and they're waiting
they're waiting for their turn to get
yanked into the Coast Guard Chopper
right it's just so and they'll [__]
be on the thing hanging on it
for like 20 minutes and it's like dude
you didn't do anything
other than make your arms go to sleep
[Laughter]
oh hey I'm lashing on everybody because
I [__] can't stand it I'm so [__]
mad at myself
that I've got myself into this [__]
position that I'm gonna have to go there
for like two and a half months just just
to be acceptable looking
um
I'm telling you dude you eat your way in
and out of the gym and I swear to God oh
Billy fat face did a [__] number man
the holidays and then that [__] world
tour
I actually did well in the world tour I
was [__] hitting the uh I was hitting
the gems when I could just making a huge
difference and then I went to New York
and it was just a [__] [__] show
you know what I mean you know you get
drunk all Pizza tastes good when you're
drunk you don't give a [__] right
throw those goddamn delis get a bacon
egg and cheese at [__] two in the
morning oh that's good bill there you go
we think that's going huh right to your
[__] man tits you freckled [__]
so I did that for I don't know I don't
know I don't even know how long started
in November right before Thanksgiving I
started you know you just start shifting
around in your chair and you feel it ah
you put not a little weight there bill
what are you gonna do about it I don't
want to go to the gym I want more Fritos
right I was stuck in it the sugar salt
addiction it had me
when I was writing on F is for family we
had Frito Fridays we get a big giant bag
in these [__] awesome sandwiches and
it was it was great
it was great until now
now that I'm on the elliptical so um
I actually go into the gym and this is I
actually to get an hour's worth of
cardio if you're a Stephen Adler fan you
can listen to basically
um
I listen I don't know if I already told
you this well this is what I do when I
have to knock out an hour of cardio
obviously the towel goes over the timer
because I don't want to [__] look at
it
and I I put on
Civil War the only track that Steven
played drums on in the use your illusion
albums and then I just listen appetite
from front to back
and I basically look at it this way
you got an hour right break it down to
15 minute quarters like a game
Civil War
into [__] Welcome to the Jungle and
then somewhere in uh it's so easy you
got your first 15 minutes because Civil
War is a long [__] song
all right it's like seven minutes of
some [__] what we've got here all right
and then you figure your next three
which are uh Night Train it's so easy
and Mr Brownstone that takes you almost
up to a half hour it all depends on when
you press play
then you're into Paradise City my
Michelle so the game's half over then
Paradise City my Michelle and think
about you
all right
then you're coming up on 45 minutes
you're in the final [__] stretch then
all it is is uh
Sweet Child
you crazy
uh what's the other one uh anything goes
and then you warm down his uh Rocket
Queen
and you're [__] done that's all I do
and I'm getting sick of that because I
keep [__] doing that every goddamn
day
and um I'll just have to sweat you gotta
have like a classic album that you just
like everything wire to [__] wire and
the musicians in the band didn't put out
some [__] 40 minute album they
actually put out a good like 50 minutes
of music
and um
I don't know at that point you're
throwing one of the [__] song and
you're good to go am I Born you with
this [__] well that's how [__] bored
I am at the goddamn gym
what's up with these Meatheads that walk
around they got like a gallon of [__]
water
then they're never sweating either they
walk around they got that tape handle on
it walking around like a [__] ape
right is that what they're gonna drink
all day I don't understand why they're
doing that although I do appreciate the
beautiful ladies in the spin class when
I walk by with the little half shirts on
that's kind of nice before I walk into
the misery
the [__] gym knowing I'm doing chess
that day and there's no [__] way to
bet oh you know it's another [__]
[__] move is the guy who you
to do like ab work and tricep dips and
then he just [__] sits there and this
everybody goes for the [__] weight
bench nobody does squats you know what I
mean go do your [__] ab work on the
squat machine you [__] right all right
that's it I'm done bitching
all right there we go Jesus [__]
Christ
oh Bill why did you do this to yourself
it was funny when as I put on weight too
I always go I'm putting on weight I'm
putting on weight and then I don't want
to get on the scale because I don't want
to [__] see what I already know but
if I just get on the scale the second I
felt it I'd feel disgusted halfway down
the road instead of being all the way
down the [__] road so
anyways that's it I'm done
I'm done [__] uh
done [__] ragging at this point
um
I don't mean that [__] hand sanitizer
is always out at the [__] gym it has
Jesus Christ
I'm not a gym guy I just don't [__]
like are they gonna why don't you just
file that [__] guy
I'm watching Duke uh San Diego State
right now and that Okafor whatever his
name is he did that Pau Gasol thing
where he dunks the ball first of all
he's like nine feet tall so it's like me
dunking on a Nerf hoop and he dunks the
ball after a fast break and what does he
do after he dunks the ball he does that
stupid yelling
oh
I think you ought to get teed up for
that
technical foul for being a douche what
are you doing
quit acting like you're in [__]
Braveheart it just it drives me up to
fight I don't
they never did that when I was a kid
Larry Bird would [__] hit a
three-pointer
to win the game and all I do is stick
his you know his index finger in the air
like yeah there you go number one
it's over he just backpedal down the
accordion ah
like he's this you know half man half
[__] I don't know wildebeest is that
the right animal
ah Jesus this is all the misery of
you're listening to a sore old man
who realizes he has another two and a
half months of [__] work in the gym
and he's ready to quit right now and go
get himself a cupcake
by the way I gotta hand to the Greeks
man they got great food don't they but I
will tell you this they cannot make a
dessert to save their [__] lives
I'll [__] you with the honey Jesus
Christ why don't you just take a
honeycomb and roll it and flower and
throw it at me
it's just it just tastes like ass it's
like they take wallpaper and they layer
it up with honey in the middle of it
that's what [__] baklavac is a
baklava however the [__] you say
everything else though outstanding
maybe that's where I need to live maybe
I should go move to Greece I'd never get
dessert not because I don't want it it's
because they don't make a good dessert
and then I would be cutting those
calories out
then I could finish my dinner and after
I was done dinner and they'd be like do
you want do you want dessert I'd be like
no they go no no I don't then when they
walk away I go
like I just did something amazing
does that work for you
well I don't give a [__] it works for me
what's with your attitude this week huh
what happened to you what'd you do this
weekend it makes you feel so goddamn
important
did you fill out your brackets
um
so anyways Jesus Christ you know what I
have to say is I have so much [__] I
have to [__] do today
and uh and study for my [__] I'm in
the bubble guys I'm in the bubble
I don't know when I'm taking the test
but uh for the helicopter license but uh
I am in the bubble right now I'm testing
every day that e6b is my [__] [__]
right now
it's my [__] that thing I [__]
couldn't stand that little stupid
computer thing with the goddamn wheel
and after a while once you start
figuring out you really appreciate the
genius of whoever it is that came up
with that thing
I'll tell you whoever came up with that
thing if he did it while TV existed
that's one of the smartest human beings
that ever lived you know
I'm gonna go out on a limit I'm gonna
say a man is the person that came up
with that and the only reason why it
wasn't a woman was because of you fill
in the blank you fill in the blank with
the excuse
because we're not allowed to play with
paper during that decade
this has nothing to do with sexism this
just has to do with me I [__] hate
going to the gym don't like going to I
don't want to do this I don't want to do
this a second I get it done it's [__]
over
um
anyways
what else Jesus Christ my Bruins
a [__] ripping my hat out right now
you know right when I thought they were
putting it back together
we got the capitals we got Ottawa we got
big games and we just [__] lose all
of them I haven't even seen the Ottawa
game I was working that night and I just
you know I followed the Bruins on my
phone and I just kept saying
how anytime there's 10 goals in a game
that's a pretty insane game I have it on
I have a TV ad I'm gonna watch it as
much as it's gonna kill me but even last
night we [__] lost
and overtime to the [__] uh
Florida Panthers
and Ottawa one again so now like I don't
know what the standings are but we're
like the eighth seed by the skinny skin
of our teeth
um
I don't know
oh [__] we're playing Tampa Bay right
now or coming up
we got a [__] Tampa Bay is tough too
ah who am I kidding do we don't we don't
have it this year
I thought we were getting hot I thought
we were going to be right Bruins face
lightning with one point lead for second
wild card in the east
Jesus Christ
I still think the winner comes from the
West what do you guys think
still think they're better
um speaking of hockey I was hanging out
with Joe bartnick Rose Bowl tailgate
Legend Joe bartnick and um
he said gun to his head he was picking
the Blackhawks and he said maybe St
Louis Blues I don't want to misquote
them but uh if you want to hear the best
hockey show that I know of
uh you got to listen to his uh his Puck
off podcast Joe bartnick uh it's one of
my favorites and even though he [__]
ripped the Bruins apart I couldn't argue
with a lot of what he was saying but um
I think this week rumored has it he
might be going at his own Pittsburgh
Penguins
so we'll see what happens with that but
uh but anyways this is the Monday
Morning podcast I do one of these every
goddamn week and then I check in on you
on Thursdays that's how it works I'll
tell you had a rough one you know
Jesus Christ
why do I do this to myself what is it
that makes you just you and you know
you're gaining weight just makes you not
get on the [__] scale
it just makes it worse
if you're sitting there right now and
you know you're putting on weight and
you don't want to step on the scale do
yourself the biggest [__] favor right
now stop listening to this podcast go in
step on the scale and see what the
damage is
it's gonna be uh up Duke beat [__]
San Diego State they pulled away in the
end one by 19. um
you know if you don't do it now you're
just going to keep going you're going to
keep going further and you're going to
be as miserable as I am right now
[__] miserable
um
Jesus Christ why did I do that to myself
Jesus Christ I look like the [__]
Michelin man I had it well though
I'll tell you you're gonna hide a good
25 pounds of [__] absolute [__] with
a [__] button-down shirt you know
that
well that's what I used to say it was
you're in sport coat shape button-down
shirt shape t-shirt shape
wife beater shape
no shirt shape and then the ultimate is
no shirt sitting down in shape that's
right there that is the the In-Shape
pyramid
all right now and right now I am
somewhere between I'm like a button-down
shirt shape
um
I'll tell you if you really want to
discuss yourself
you know because you really got to be
disgusted with yourself before you
finally work out I find this is what you
should do stand
shirtless in the mirror looking at
yourself
with a pair of dad jeans and suspenders
okay
and the level of disgust you'll have for
yourself you'll be dragging your ass to
the [__] gym like I am
um
and I apologize for how [__] I'm being
this week um anyways um I'm heading back
East coming up here in uh a little bit
and um
let's just wonder if it's is it still
snowing in New York
is it melting are there ice dams is the
world ending back there
I have no [__] idea
I'm heading back there
coming back there soon I just got to hit
the gym for the rest of this [__]
week and then I'll
go to New York next week and everything
will be fine
and I'll be back there with all the
[__] animals
that I used to drink with and eat pizza
late at night with and I'm just gonna
have to [__] somehow plow through
that [__] but anyways you don't want to
hear about that [__] why don't we why
don't we go [__] take a quick look at
some uh some world news some world news
some news from the world
um
as always I never go to U.S uh news
sites I try to stay away from those
[__] things because I always hear all
that [__] anyways if I don't hear it on
the news I hear comedians talking about
it so I like going to [__] Al Jazeera
I like checking out seeing what Al's
talking about son of Ukraine's
ex-president drowns in a Russian Lake
the youngest son of Ukraine's former
president Victor
what a [__] great name yonokovic
Victor yanokovic sounds like a [__]
Hall of Fame defenseman
um has died after his vehicle plunged
through the ice near the Russian
Mongolian border
the [__] was he doing all the way over
there an associate of the the post
president said oh deposed the guy got
booted
now what did he do did he stick a cigar
in somebody's [__] on set on Sunday that
the 33 year old Victorian yonokovic who
had the same name as his father was
driving at the time of his death
Russian authorities have not identified
a driver who died on Friday when a mini
bus carrying six people smashed through
thin ice on Lake
bakel or confirm reports that it was
yonokovic's son the five passengers
survived wait a minute what are you
talking about this guy was driving a bus
I don't [__] you the son of the
president you're driving a bus carrying
six people he must have been the rebel
of the family
you know didn't want to follow on his
dad's footsteps said [__] this
I'm gonna go drive the [__] hurt
shuttle
just north of Mongolia
is that what he did
Jesus Christ what a [__] way to go
I'll tell you what it will never always
amaze me is when [__] Ted Kennedy
went into that goddamn Lake
you know what I mean you think the
weight of his giant head alone I mean
that guy's head is like a was like a
safe I saw that guy I shook his hand one
time
um it's a long story right after I shook
Bill Clinton's hand I was standing um
standing on the side of the road
in Boston and uh
a buddy of mine wanted to go down and
see it he's like oh the president's
coming down let's go look at the [__]
motorcade me and this other [__]
friend of mine who was a total pothead
and we could give a [__] we were
bleary-eyed we went down there
and uh Clinton came down the street and
he just wanted to see the motorcade
right as he was coming to drive by us
the motor came dipped down this [__]
alley
and then we're looking at our body going
yeah that was great dude they [__]
made a left turn and now we didn't see
it and they go no no he's going there to
make a speech he'll probably be in there
for like an hour I'm gonna go get a
slice of pizza you guys want anything
we're like nah we're good we're good so
the dude who wants to see the motorcade
goes off to go see if get a [__]
slice of pizza me and the pothead a
[__] standing there not giving a [__]
all of a sudden the crowd starts going
nuts
right
going [__] crazy in these Secret
Service guys we're behind this police
scare barricades tell everybody put
their hands up keep your hands up hold
hands up we can see it keep your hands
up you're like freaking out and all of a
sudden Here Comes old slick Willy
walking up the [__] Street
high-fiving people
well the the well his limo is driving
slowly along next to him with the
[__] door open and walking right
behind him was [__] Ted Kennedy
so uh I high-fived Bill Clinton when he
was president
before Monica Lewinsky this is his first
term right soft hands
soft like [__]
I don't know what
creepy soft [__] hands little hands
little soft [__] baby gross hands but
he did have long piano playing fingers
it was not a good experience
I didn't want to be there right and then
Ted Kennedy came went to high-five him
in the sheer size the sheer mass of the
guy's head I literally went whoa
you couldn't [__] believe the fact
that get that guy his head was so big he
never should have had a full head of
hair just thought of this the sheer like
surface area of it
that just even if he had a full head of
hair it's not gonna be a full head with
that [__] head
I'll tell you right now thank God that
guy didn't go bald man Jesus Christ that
would have been that would have been
something to look at
um
so I shook his [__] hand and Jesus
Christ he just looked like you know
I know he was sober at that point but
that guy that guy lived a [__] he you
know he lived a rough one you know
[__] lost three of his brothers this
thing that happened to his sister the
whole [__] crazy and he goes in the lake
he kills somebody
oh my God can you imagine his [__]
wife sleeping next to him how much does
that guy talk in his sleep
I had nothing to do with it come in
another Direction
Jack it down get down
um that's brutal anyways
so then Bill Clinton jumps in his
[__] car Ted Kennedy jumps in with
them and they just [__] take off
and everybody's like oh my God I can't
believe it oh my God and everybody just
sort of walks away
and then like all of that took maybe
like 17 seconds
and then everybody was gone and the
whole [__] thing was over it was like
it never happened and then we turn
around
and here comes my buddy coming up the
street fighting into a slice of pizza
I've never forget he bites in
and then he like stopped mid bite and he
looks around and he goes
ah [__]
he's like did I miss it
because did I miss it
and I go yeah and I go uh
I shook his hand
he goes what
go he came walking up the street I I
shook his head and my body goes no you
didn't and then he looks over I look
over and there's my pothead friend who's
like Galloping in a circle
and he's just jumping up and down as
he's Galloping and he's going I shook it
twice I shook it twice
laughs
ah if you could have seen the look on
that dude's face he was so [__]
disappointed we didn't even tell him
about Ted Kennedy
um anyways so there's that story
there's that story for you
um
so anyways baseball season is starting
up I'm wondering what my Red Sox are
going to do this year they went out and
they spent a bunch of [__] money
Yankees haven't spent any money man
they're in a weird place right now
um but I'm excited for baseball this
year I hope it goes the way it did last
year I'd like to see more Baltimore
Tampa Kansas City
maybe Cleveland
you know Milwaukee I liked all those all
those [__] teams you know what I mean
I like uh
I like seeing like you know
I'd like to see the Padres do something
somebody different you know I like what
the Dodgers did last year too but um you
know it's kind of hard to be a fan of a
team that goes out and blows spends all
the [__] money I know it's legal in
that type of [__] but it's just the way
that they run that League it's just they
should do it more like football which I
hope they're doing and I hope last year
was not like this anomaly did I say that
right I lost confidence as I was saying
that's why I went anomaly anomaly
um oh good good oh the guy Clark
Kellogg's gonna act out a basketball
shot thank god oh here we go yeah do it
in your wing tips
now here comes the other guy now what
you want to do is Pivot here now you see
if you do that that's called the travel
like this does anybody learn the game of
basketball right here like you don't
[__] did I just say the game of
basketball like a Michael Jordan
um
oh Jesus Christ why do they do this who
is the person that came up with this
like you know let's get half a football
field in here and have these old guys
get down in that three-point stance hey
well why can't we do that with
basketball that's what I love about
hockey they don't they can't do it I
want to go out there with street hockey
sticks
um
it's so dumb why do they wear suits too
by the way they're [__] pro athletes
okay just get in there in their
sweatpants and t-shirts
what's with with the haberdash
I you know something I am like
36 minutes into this podcast I don't
think I've liked one thing yet this is
an all-time
like negative podcast that I'm putting
out here I gotta say something positive
how about this if you guys when's the
last time you visited the all things
Comedy Network go to all
thingscomedy.com and check out all the
podcasts that we have
um
[Music]
Felipe Esparza this week he has boxer
Roy Tapia I hope I said that right and
UFC fighter Sean uh Jesus I'm gonna get
killed in this one
loafler loafero Lo Fuller
l-o-e-f-f-l-e-r
um we got Doug Stanhope we got the verzy
effect dude the all things com all
things Comedy Network is the best
podcasting Network out there bar none if
you look at the quality of shows Ari
shaffir Tom Papa are you kidding me
Harlan Williams
Bert Kreischer
your mom's house come on man we got
[__] everybody on this thing uh
quality control here just go on to the
podcast uh Network all things comedy and
just start clicking on some podcasts and
I guarantee you uh you're gonna have a
good time and I'll probably lose some
listeners for whatever gives a [__] as
long as the money goes to other
comedians right
um all right let's get into some
questions for the week here
this is the advertising this is not what
I want all right here we go um
all right and by the way if you'd like
to send emails to the Monday Morning
podcast
um the email is Bill at themmpodcast.com
bill at the mmpodcast.com and if you'd
like to follow us on Twitter it's at the
mm podcast
at
the mm podcast uh Clark Kellogg acting
out a [__] layup oh Jesus Christ all
right Thursday afternoon Thursday
afternoon Monday Morning podcast
um news I've been doing those lately
I'll do another one this week dear Billy
overtime
thanks for the extra podcast my wife and
I have a longer commute on Mondays and
Fridays and a couple months ago she said
how about you write in and ask Bill if
he can do another one on Fridays I told
her not to get greedy and that we're
lucky the man hasn't retired yet Jesus
am I that old lo and behold you did it
and since it's the Thursday afternoon
podcast it perfectly it's perfectly
wrapped for us to listen to Listen to
Friday mornings love you love Nia thanks
again couple of commuters from Ontario
nice Ontario Canada
are you are you Maple Leaf fans
you know who else is in Ontario Toronto
Ontario
I already forget where the [__] is
Quebec which Providence is that in
not Quebec you idiot I mean Ottawa is
Ottawa in Quebec or is in Ontario
I don't know but I do know it's the
capital and that the [__] River
freezes over and you can skate to work
and I've been there how about that is
that isn't that enough for you
um well thank you for listening
um I'm actually looking at a Toronto
date possibly in the fall it all depends
I got a little bit of acting work
all right oh Billy Shakespeare was going
to do possibly another movie or two uh
later on this year and uh oh I want to
thank everybody who went out to go see
zomb beavers uh please continue to see
it I got a lot of hilarious emails about
it saying that it was funny
it uh made fun of zombie movies and had
respect for it and they actually jumped
like three or four times was
legitimately scary
a lot of nudity in it you know old
school [__] horror [__] um once again
directed by uh Jordan Rubin stand-up
comic that I started out with a long
time ago so uh that always helps that
helps me out you know of [__] that I'm
in does well so thank you guys for
checking it out and um
if you don't get a chance to check it
out in movie theaters please uh download
legally
so you can see more movies about rodents
and varmints to turn into zombies
um by the way I watched it again you got
to see Sam Rockwell and moon I swear to
God you got to see that [__] thing
I'm not a big sci-fi guy and uh it was
so good uh Nee and I were actually
saying that we want to watch more sci-fi
so if you have some good Sci-Fi
am I slowly turning into a [__] what
is that what does that think Comic-Con
am I gonna be one of those people I'm
already dressing up like drummers and
[__] what's the difference between that
and dressing up like Spock
I don't know all right woman in the
warehouse I love when I get letters from
females I never get them on this thing
hey woman in the warehouse dear Bill I'm
a 27 year old lady
and I work in a warehouse in Philly hey
good for you I used to work in
warehousing
it's one of my favorite [__] jobs I
ever had
and I always said that if I wasn't going
to get older and I wasn't going to turn
30 someday
um I would have stayed there forever
because it was such a fun [__] job it
was physical you got a good workout and
everybody that worked in the warehouse
was either a Class Clown a struggling
musician
uh uh a [__] drug addict it was
everybody was a character out there and
they were all [__] hilarious
I loved I never understood wanting to
get into the carpet area and get
yourself a little Michael J fox
you know what was that sitcommy's Family
Ties dressing up like him with your
goddamn loafers
you know acting like you're in there
making decisions the decisions have been
made for you
you know you go and you sit in your
little half a [__] office and you act
accordingly
um he says uh she says I work in a
warehouse in Philly it involves some
manual labor and I like it it's just
part-time
um as I'm getting my masters in English
what are you working at uh UPS
that was the big thing back then eight
dollars an hour
to [__] work harder than you'll ever
work in your life unloading those trucks
[__] thing heavy ass 70 boxes and
then you have like an entire exhaust
system that job's a [__]
um the guys in the warehouse are cool
but they always act like I'm gonna rat
them to HR if I hear them make jokes
about women Etc what can I say to end
this any advice
um
well first of all you're cool if you
don't mind that they do it but you have
to understand
um that's the climate right now is that
if the you make any sort of any joke if
you say anything
about women other than
you know well I'll tell you it's a damn
shame that more women don't blah blah
blah if you say anything about women the
way you say hello to them and all they
have to do is just say that you're
making them uncomfortable
um and next thing you know they're
losing their job and then they have this
[__] creepy sex thing on their
[__] resume
sexual harassment or some [__] like that
so uh
I don't know if I hear them make any
jokes about what can I say to end this
any advice
um you know what I wouldn't get involved
in it
I wouldn't get I don't know why you want
to get involved in it I don't know why
you want to open that Pandora's Box no
pun intended
just stay away from it all right
don't you're gonna get them in trouble
or worst case scenario you're gonna be
one of those people like nah I'm totally
cool I'm not with that how could you say
that and then you go actually go to HR
and I'm not saying you're one of these
women but you are a woman so you know
what I'm talking about
all right
talking about the old bait and switch
with the hoo-ha there so stay away
don't go [__] you know Don't Go Over
There biting the Apple
all right the parameters have been set
by a bunch of [__] people [__]
moaning and complaining and people
adhere to those rules so every one of
those guys by you opening the door
saying guys I don't care if you [__]
talk about women in a derogatory way
you're opening a door for all of them to
get fired so it seems to me that you
want to be one of the guys and you want
to be cool so if you want to do that
then just [__] respect the fact that
they're respecting you and don't pick at
that scab because you're going to get
them in trouble
all right
there you go
um
where else too that makes me uh God it
makes me wish I was still in my 20s
again there was nothing better than that
you worked in the warehouse all day and
once a week you played softball against
some other [__] warehouse and at the
end of the game you oh it's the best we
used to go to this [__] uh
you know in Massachusetts like every
other town
just has like
you know their place that claims they
have the best bar pizza so it would
almost be like a small pizza that you
get at some chain thing
and um we had the place where where I
was at which I'm not going to say the
name of because I don't want [__]
bunch of people going there so when I go
there I gotta stand in line but um we
used to go to the original location it's
since changed and of course people
bitched and moaned dude all the original
flavors in those old onions ovens right
you know
it's like no it isn't all your memories
are there your grandfather took you
there and you're sad so now you're going
to say the pizza doesn't taste as good
they [__] literally moved like 20
[__] minutes down the street all
right grow up not even that it's like a
[__] six minute drive so anyways we
used to go there afterwards and uh
oh it's the [__] best
you worked all day you played softball
and you just slam like [__] six beers
eat a pizza
and then drive home because it was the
[__] 80s you know drive home buzzed
which was stupid but you know
and uh
pass out wake up and do it all over
again
um
I always enjoy I enjoy manual labor jobs
that are inside I was I did not enjoy
manual labor outside just because I
would get sunburned like a [__]
but um I did like driving around with
people when they were plow plowing uh
plowing driveways and going out and
shoveling snow but uh you really [__] up
your back
that's how Larry Bird same thing Larry
Bird blacktop his parents driveway
and you know that little stupid little
stick [__] handle thing that's built
for a guy my size he was like six ten
bent over at the [__] waist doing
that his back was never the same but uh
I never hear that [__] I don't know
makes me happy that I have a job where I
don't have to
[__] lift anything you know it's
funny I was making fun of Bill Clinton's
[__] soft hands I have soft hands the
only calluses I have on my hands at this
point is from doing pull-ups
[Laughter]
Oh Billy soft Dance all right uh repeat
television
hey Bill
TV like every other American and citizen
of the world I watch a lot of Seinfeld
and Simpson reruns I was wondering what
shows he wrote shoes what shows you uh
you're able to watch over and over again
also what shows could you watch as a kid
that were before your time
oh what that I would I was not mature
enough to watch
or we're groundbreaking
um well that's a great question let's
see what shows can I watch over and over
and over again The Simpsons you already
said them
uh um
let's see you know what is there's not a
lot of them
because I really got into sports
you know in my teens so
I used to watch Family Ties I would
watch
um
I would watch uh cheers
I tried to watch The Cosby Show
but I couldn't stand his wife on the
show
when she would do that stupid joke where
she knew well clear it's going to do
this and then clip and clear if I hated
the thing and then I hated that overly
cutesy [__] he would do with the kids
like it was a Jello commercial
and um but I did like the show when I
would actually give it a [__] chance
I like the show
um
but I I don't know I I just it was just
there was such goody goody it was like
the [__] Brady Bunch I just can't get
into that [__] you know it means it's
goody goody his family ties was I at
least like that Michael J fox character
was kind of a dick he was like a
republican which I thought was different
you know I know that was probably
another awful one I can't remember I
would say but the [__] that I actually
go back and watch
um was just all [__] from my childhood
um like I'll watch an episode of chips
now I love watching chips whenever it
comes on because I live in LA now so I
try to guess which Highway they're on
what which one they're filming
um which one they're filming on
oh watch Charlie's Angels I guess that
was ahead of my time I will watch
Charlie's Angels
um Beretta which was considered really
violent SWAT the rookies Six Million
Dollar Man
um those are all the show Happy Days
it's probably the one cornball one that
I watched
and then I would watch reruns of the
monkeys I saw every episode of the
monkeys every episode of The Brady Bunch
uh and then I watched all the westerns
Bonanza Big Valley
what's the one with the the guy would
[__] The Rifleman
his stupid son used to always call him
paw he used to drive me nuts [__]
dude would cry like every [__] three
episodes I couldn't stand him Batman
Jesus Christ they've wasted a lot of
[__] time didn't they
yeah mostly [__] back then but then in
the 90s I started doing stand-up in like
1992 so I never even really saw Seinfeld
I just remember hearing about it by 93
it blew up and everyone was talking
about it was on the cover like Rolling
Stone and [__] but I didn't really watch
it
until it came into reruns because then
it came on during a time where I could
actually see it
um
what do I watch now I watch Archer
uh
uh I watch
last man on Earth
I don't know now in TV watching is
different now it's like you go on
Netflix and you like binge watch
like I still haven't started Better Call
Saul and I know that you know maybe next
week when I go on the road I'm going to
watch the pilot episode in the second
one I have every other one taped what
happened to me was that show started
when I was overseas and I forgot to set
my [__] DV yeah
so I gotta get caught up in that old
Joey roses is in it Joe Del Rosa with a
something and the something something
so a lot of people have been asking me
hey Bill are you gonna be on Better Call
Saul and this is what I'll tell you if
you guys keep watching I have a good
feeling that eventually because it's a
prequel the closer he gets to meeting
Walter White at some point
I might drop that my character might
come back that's all I know okay I'm not
in the writer's room I have no idea so
uh if you could if you could keep
watching it I'd appreciate it listen to
me as I haven't even started I'm
starting this week all right that's my
promise to you
and I'm going to keep going to the gym
even though I don't like it
um all right thanks and go [__] yourself
all right camping
hey Bill you ever do any serious or
casual camping is that something you
think you could do you you but is that
something you think you could Nia into
you mean talk Nia into
um I've gone on some fun trips as a kid
and recently with friends and I'm trying
to help my girlfriend to go she's
hesitant I assured her it would be warm
weather camping there'd be swimming and
s'mores and all that all that stuff
thoughts on camping
um and whether a chick should just relax
for a weekend without a curling iron go
[__] yourself
I always wanted to say that
um the white Cam no I respect it
but um I think I went camping once I
told this story before I met this chick
at a college and she's like we were
going camping I was like well I want to
hook up with you so yeah I'll go and uh
I don't know what happened next thing
I'm out there I'm like [__] 30 I'm
hanging with these college kids and I
was like what the [__] am I doing out
here we got hammered and nothing ended
up happening and I think I puked in a
tent which means I did puke in a tent
but I'm embarrassed so even years later
I had to say I think I puked in a tent
um so that's my experience
um I don't know on my bucket list is
getting mauled is not on my bucket list
so I'm not into like I would go camping
if I had
uh uh a [__] Glock and a rifle I
would do that but I don't like that [__]
where I'm sleeping in a tent and then a
bear comes up and smells my food or
something and then looks at the tent and
can smell me and I'm the tent and me
become like a fruit roll-up or a burrito
Oh Billy burrito and that thing just
starts biting my head
[__] that
[__] that but I do respect people that
actually go out there and um
know how to [__] rough it and live
off the land you know with your
state-of-the-art tents and your [__]
heated socks but as far as your
girlfriend not wanting to go uh why make
a
winemaker she's going to be miserable
which is going to make you miserable why
don't you just have that be the thing
that you do that's just separate time
from her absent makes the heart grow
fonder and then you guys come back
together why don't you why don't you
just do that instead of trying to
trying to talk her into that [__] and I
would never try to talk my wife into
that stuff uh I've asked her a couple of
times and she has no [__] desire
on any level she's a city girl she does
not want to go [__] being a tent you
want to rent a house by a lake you know
with windows and doors and a fireplace
she's all about it but you know as far
as like going out there
eating beans with a knife out of a
[__] can yeah no she's not into that
all right let's read the last couple of
advertisers here and then um we'll wrap
up the thing here um all right well
that is the uh that is the podcast
for this week I hope you enjoyed it I
want to thank everybody that's been
writing in love hearing from the ladies
and
um
I don't know I got a crazy week coming
up and I'll I'll be telling telling you
about it hopefully uh on Thursday
remember the Thursday podcast Oh Billy
redface just checking in seeing how you
doing on payday
um oh and once again I know I've hiked
this for two weeks in a row but check
out Sam Rockwell and moon and also check
out uh Chris uh I hate Christian later
um
that I Moon I'm actually going to buy
that on DVD that's how much I enjoyed
that [__] movie it's I just can't
imagine how difficult that must have
been
um to shoot to perform and all that type
of thing it's just just an awesome
awesome movie all right that's it go
Bruins For the Love of Christ